there is a legal expert norm eisen
who believes at this point without a
doubt that donald trump is heading
towards an indictment and that trump's
allies have started to relieve to
receive target letters which are
different than we want you to testify
target letters are
you are actually a target
in this investigation
um let's discuss
with the caveat that great until trump
is actually charged i remain skeptical
that anything's going to happen newsweek
report trump heading towards an
indictment as allies receive warnings
uh attorney norman eisen predicted
friday that former president donald
trump is heading towards an indictment
in georgia after some of his allies
there received so-called target letters
from the fulton county da's office now i
want to remind everybody
a month ago maybe six weeks ago i said
that i don't think charges against trump
are likely
but if there are going to be charges
i believe the likeliest source
is the investigation in georgia where
there was so much evidence recorded
evidence phone calls pressure campaigns
back channels trying to get specific
georgia officials this wasn't just oh i
went on the news and said i won or we
held a hearing where rudy giuliani had
flatulence and also you know said that i
won this was specific phone calls
this was targeting brad raffensberger
this was
sending lindsey deputizing lindsey
graham to go in and say well can't we
look at it and see if maybe we can do
something find a different conclusion i
believe that the most likely source of
charges would be georgia and that is
indeed what normizen is saying
the georgia county d.a fannie willis
launched the investigation into trump
early last year after he pressured
officials in the state to help overturn
president joe biden's election win that
effort drew national attention after
audio of a call between trump and
georgia's secretary of state brad
raffensberger leaked in which trump or
urged him to find enough votes to change
the outcome
yahoo news first reported friday that
david schaefer the state of republican
sharon georgia and state senators bert
jones and brandon beach have received
target letters from willis warning they
could face indictment in connection to
her investigation jeff desantis a
spokesperson for the d.a also said
willis is considering subpoenaing trump
to testify before the special grand jury
convened for the probe eisen said to the
new york times i do believe that the
great likelihood is he's heading towards
an indictment
the legal expert previously served
special counsel to the house judiciary
during trump's first impeachment
there is powerful proof of violations of
georgia law in the form of the smoking
gun tape of him demanding 11 780 votes
when it is perfectly clear from the tape
that he knows the votes don't exist yes
and that is an important point
some have very meekly and flaccidly
and and not
credibly tried to defend trump's request
for 11 780 votes by saying
he's not saying fraudulently get me
those votes he's just saying
i believe i really won
it's not that big of a gap to overcome
let's find legal votes
anyone who has listened to that tape
knows that that is not at all what he
was trying to say so
fascinating interesting the news
headlines for the last three years have
been trump is heading to an indictment
uh personally i know people convinced
that donald trump is going to be charged
and we may see headlines for the next
six months saying any day now any day
now trump's going to be charged if it
happens i will be the first to tell you
i am not confident that that's going to
take place now one other thing and i
want to think ahead here a little bit
because this is another important issue
imagine trump gets indicted okay
imagine that the indictment goes to
trial unlikely but imagine we get
through those two steps imagine that
there's a jury trial
how do you get a jury
that will be able to properly and fairly
adjudicate a donald trump case if you
have one trump cultist on the jury you
have a hung jury how do you even do jury
selection i mean think about how do you
find someone who has no opinion about
trump and no significant preconceived
notions of his guilt or innocence and
then the the next layer is if you think
about there are non-political people
there are people who know nothing and
care nothing about who's president they
just don't pay attention
but are those people we trust to be in
the position of even adjudicating the
case think about people you know who
have no idea
what has gone on the last six years are
those people that we would be confident
saying this is a jury of our peers and
they will adjudicate this doesn't seem
like it to me so that's sort of like a
second order issue if we ever got an
indictment and had to pick a jury but
we'll deal with that later nor eisen
says trump is heading towards an
indictment and at least to some degree
trump must think it's possible because
the report from rolling stone is he
plans to run for 24 and it's to keep
himself out of prison essentially away
from criminal charges as he sees it
what do you expect let me know